Of all the dislocations caused
by government responses to COVID,
arguably, none were more disruptive
to everyday life than the shutting
down of in-person education
for the country's 50 million
K-through-12 students and their
parents.
Teachers unions fought to keep
schools online, even as evidence
piled up that remote learning was
disastrous, especially
for poor kids.
And as the experiences of other
developed countries, which mostly
continue to operate in-person,
demonstrated that schools weren't
a major source of infection.
The results were easy to predict.
Historic declines in reading
and math scores.
Major school districts continue to
alienate parents with Washington,
D.C., recently decreeing
that kids ages 12 and older
would need to be vaccinated even
for remote learning, a measure
that would have barred 40%
of the city's black teens from
getting an education.
The policy was thankfully pushed
back until January of 2023.
But it's still on the books, lurking
like a bully at the far end of the
home life. More parents than ever
have exited major urban school
districts, and school choice
proponents are building on recent
policy victories, such as Arizona's
new law, in which money follows
the child with up to $7,000
that can be used that any public or
private school in the state.
The politics of school choice are
already a major issue in the midterm
elections and will be again in 2024,
especially as internal polls
conducted by the American Federation
of Teachers find for the first time
that voters in battleground states
are more likely to agree that
Republicans are better on education
than Democrats.
So what happens next at
Freedom Fest? The annual July
gathering in Las Vegas.
Reason talked with Corey DeAngelis,
a senior fellow at the American
Federation of Children, and a senior
fellow at Reason Foundation, which
publishes Reason.com.
We talked about how COVID has
permanently reshaped the education
landscape. Why top-down bans
on critical race theory are
ineffective and anti-freedom?
Why some red states like Texas
are terrible on choice?
And why all of us, whether we have
kids in K-through-12 schools or not,
should be invested in radical
reform.
Corey DeAngelis, thanks for talking
to Reason.
Thank you so much for having me.
So there is a
leaked poll that is
really kind of, you know, that
sheds a weird light and a kind
of wonderful light for school choice
people on,
you know, school choice issues
coming into the midterm elections
and beyond. It was it was
commissioned by the American
Federation for Teachers.
So this was a poll that was supposed
to show one of the biggest teachers
unions how well they are positioned
going into things.
What's the poll say?
And, you know, what's the fallout?
Yeah, it doesn't look good for the
teachers unions is essentially an
epic self-own by Randi Weingarten
and her union, the American
Federation of Teachers.
So this is a poll of likely voters
in battleground states like
Pennsylvania and others conducted
by or for is for the
American Federation of Teachers.
And the top line finding was that
likely voters in these battleground
states were more likely to support
Republicans on education
as opposed to Democrats.
And so that's that's big finding
itself.
Usually, Republicans are leaning on
things like the economy and jobs,
not so much on education.
We did see this happen with Glenn
Youngkin when he won the
gubernatorial race in Virginia
against Terry McAuliffe, who was the
Senate, was a former incumbent
in the state, in a state that went
ten percentage points to Biden,
Glenn Youngkin won by two percentage
points. And according to Washington
Post exit polling, he won with
education voters by about
six percentage points.
And education was the number two
issue in that election.
Now, that was schools coming really
coming directly out of COVID
and lockdowns and just arbitrariness
and and a broad sense of
teachers not caring about
education during COVID.
They were more, you know, so
now, you know, we're we're, you
know, ten months past, all
of that kind of stuff.
What what are the complaints
that parents have about
educators right now?
So people's parents had
their eyes opened.
Why? Why?
Because of the pandemic school
closures, the union induced school
closures. They got to see what was
going on in the classroom.
And the problems, as I
see it, are just symptoms
of the larger issues that we forced
millions of families to send their
kids to a one size fits
all government-run school system.
That, by definition, isn't going
to work for families who
disagree about how they want their
kids raised, how they want their
kids to be educated.
So whether it's mask mandates or
not, whether it's remote versus
in-person instruction, whether it's
this curriculum or that curriculum
or anything else, by
definition, if families are paying
attention to what's going on,
there's going to be a large segment
of the population or at least a
a sizable
part of the population that's not
going to be happy for whatever
reason, just by definition.
Yeah. And I want to also point out
that this poll also found
that Randi Weingarten
has been saying that it's been the
Republicans stoking this,
bringing politics into the
classroom.
But they also asked in their own
poll, you know what?
What's the biggest issue with public
schools? The number one issue was
overly politicized classrooms.
But then they also asked is who
is more responsible? The Republicans
are the Democrats. And by about 5 to
6 percentage points, these likely
voters were saying it's more likely
to be the Democrats
that are creating the issues with
politics in the classroom as opposed
to Republicans.